y
[Música]
sigue la inestabilidad política e
institucional en haití tras el
magnicidio el presidente llegó en el
movice el senado aplazó la investidura
de joseph lambert como presidente
interino que eligió para un cargo en un
evidente desafío a la actual
administración del primer ministro
interino claudio said
-españa reconfigura su gobierno con el
objetivo de recuperar al país de la
crisis provocada por la pandemia de kobe
19 el presidente del gobierno español
pedro sánchez hizo cambios en puestos
clave y el nuevo gabinete es más joven y
tiene mayor presencia femenina
el brillo y el glamour continúan en la
edición número 74 del festival de cine
de cannes es el primer evento de este
tipo en tener lugar desde el inicio de
la pandemia de kobe 19 tenemos informe
desde esa ciudad francesa
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos bienvenidos
y antes de seguir con la información
titulada vamos a hablar de la final de
la copa américa porque argentina venció
a brasil 1 a 0 en el estadio maracaná de
río de janeiro vemos en este momento en
directo entonces imágenes de la capital
argentina buenos aires donde cientos
miles celebran a esta hora que es la
primera victoria de la albiceleste en un
campeonato después de casi 30 años que
además es la primera leonel messi con la
selección argentina y lo ven entonces la
felicidad de los argentinos volcados a
las calles de la capital celebrando esta
victoria el gol lo hizo ángel di maria
en el primer tiempo de este partido
jugado en brásil siete finales tenía
argentina y no había ganado una hasta
hoy que ganó entonces esta copa américa
en peligro y un año después también
con 19 y va a ser en colombia también en
argentina finalmente se jugó en brasil y
los argentinos saborean entonces este
triunfo esta final bien merecida además
lo tienen los argentinos
y ahora sigamos con la información que
titulamos hace un momento en haití el
asesinato del presidente yo en el mois
el miércoles profundizó la crisis
institucional en la que este pobre país
caribeño estaba asumido desde hace ya
varios años la lucha por el poder ha
creado confusión sobre quién es el líder
legítimo de los 11 millones de
habitantes del país veamos el informe
yusef joseph lambert o haya los tres
hombres se disputan el liderazgo de
haití unas horas después del asesinato
del presidente joseph primer ministro
desde abril se declaró al frente del
país anunciando el estado de sitio y
reforzando así los poderes del ejecutivo
sin embargo uno de los últimos gestos
políticos del difunto mandatario joven
el mois fue nombrar el lunes a otro
primer ministro ariel office tras el
asesinato del presidente me convertí en
la máxima autoridad legal y regular
porque había un decreto que me nombraba
pero había lo he aún no había jurado su
cargo en el momento del asesinato para
complicar aún más las cosas tampoco hay
parlamento en funciones ya que las
elecciones legislativas que debían
celebrarse a finales de 2019 se
pospusieron sin embargo el senado de
haití que actualmente cuenta con sólo un
tercio de sus 30 asignaturas habituales
nombró el viernes a joseph lambert como
presidente interino
si como
si se hace como se está haciendo toda
esta hermosa gente llegará a un acuerdo
político que luego sería validado por
sólo el tercio del senado el hip hop
reducida mientras tanto el ministro de
elecciones mayas quien mantuvo que club
yusef mantendría ese papel hasta que las
elecciones presidenciales se celebren el
26 de septiembre tal como estaba
previsto
enfoque al camino para que se produzca
el caos porque hay grandes grupos de
personas que no quieren que haya
elecciones
por su parte martín guys la viuda del
presidente y pidió a los ciudadanos de
su país que continúen con la batalla
liderada por su difunto esposo y el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez anunció una reestructuración de
su gabinete a la que denominó el
gobierno de la recuperación económica
con el objetivo de recuperar al país de
la crisis provocada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 el mandatario hizo siete cambios
en impuestos clave y todos se dan en el
ala del partido socialista dentro de la
coalición gobernante el nuevo gabinete
es más joven y tiene mayor presencia
femenina en un contexto en el que la
derecha y la ultraderecha ganan cada vez
más terreno en el país el informe de
manuel acá no
una buena relación sin precedentes a
mitad de mandato el presidente de
gobierno español pedro sánchez anunció
siete cambios en el ejecutivo con un
claro objetivo la recuperación económica
tras la pandemia crisis que ha marcado
el gobierno actual desde su formación en
el medio de 2020 el nuevo gobierno
supone en primer lugar una renovación
generacional la edad media del anterior
ejecutivo era de 55 años el del nuevo
gobierno será de 50 años el nuevo
gobierno va a reforzar aún más la
presencia de mujeres al frente de los
ministerios
la ingeniera diana morant ocupará el
puesto de ministra de ciencia e
innovación la abogada isabel rodríguez
será la encargada del ministerio de
política territorial y portavoz del
gobierno la también jurista raquel
sánchez desempeñará el cargo de ministra
de transportes sustituye así a josé luís
ábalos uno de los nombres de peso que
abandonó en el ejecutivo como la hasta
ahora vicepresidenta primera carmen
calvo responsable de la exhumación de
francos y el proyecto de ley de memoria
democrática calvo será relevada por
félix bolaños hombre de máxima confianza
de sánchez también hay reemplazo en el
ministerio exteriores que lo lidera el
diplomático josé manuel álvarez
de que el agua sientes tensiones con
marruecos despreciarán a la ministra
gonzález la ya la cartera educativa será
ocupada por pilar alegría una de las
figuras con mayor proyección en el
partido socialista en el ministerio de
justicia entre pilar y ex presidenta del
senado con largo recorrido contra la
violencia de género fruto de la
estructuración la ministra de economía
nadie a calviño pasa de segunda primera
vicepresidenta una figura clave para
cumplir con el objetivo de salir de la
crisis económica
en sintonía con bruselas
los talibanes continúan ganando terreno
en afganistán con la captura de dos
nuevos distritos poblados por la
perseguía minorías y sahara la formación
insurgente ha capturado allá a 117 de
los 407 distritos afganos y ha afirmado
controlar el 85 por ciento del país el
avance del grupo se origina mientras
eeuu se apresura por retirar sus tropas
de territorio afgano el pentágono
reconoció el deterioro de la situación
de seguridad en esa nación en el medio
del continuado avance de los talibanes
pero aseguró que ahora es el trabajo de
las fuerzas afganas para frenar esta
expansión de los insurgentes
y continúa la edición número 74 del
festival de cine de cannes es el más
grande en celebrarse desde el inicio de
la pandemia hoy un drama sobre los
hospitales en francia y la película más
apasionada de 2.021 sacudieron alfombra
roja el informes de maría carolina piña
en nuestra de nuestra cadena aliada
radio france internacional un drama
sobre los hospitales en francia y la
película más sulfurosa del 2021
sacudieron la alfombra roja del festival
de cannes
[Música]
la directora francesa catherine corsini
cuenta en la fractura una noche caótica
en un hospital parisino durante una
manifestación de los chalecos amarillos
contra emmanuel
raf y julie una pareja al borde de la
ruptura acude a un servicio de
emergencia a punto de colapsar allí
conocen al colérico iván un camionero
herido en una manifestación de los
chalecos amarillos quien continúa
gritando en el hospital sido descontento
contra el presidente y el gobierno
francés es la fractura es un
largometraje brillante donde se mezclan
historias personales y fracturas social
y también es un homenaje al personal
hospitalario afectado por los cortes de
presupuesto antes de la pandemia el
coronavirus
después si no copiando con sus ojos
santa venidera
él siempre transgresor director holandés
paul verhoeven levantó una ola de
expectativa aquí en cannes con benedetta
un drama sobre una monja lesbiana en el
siglo 17 estatal como son vendidos
actual la actriz belga virginie efira
prestó su agraciado físico para
interpretar a esta monja italiana que
descubre los placeres de la carne cuando
se apresta a ser beatificada tras un
presunto milagro
el veterano volver joven firma aquí un
largometraje místico entre escándalo y
sensualidad basado en la historia
verdadera de esta monja condenada a la
hoguera por homosexualidad reserva como
un estado de jesús pero si esto no
quiere cumplir se ha pronunciado de amor
si no haces de cumplir
[Música]
a esta familia
y quiero cerrar entonces invitándolos al
programa a diario de copas con mi
compañero luís méndez donde les va a
llevar todos los incidentes de lo que
fue la copa américa por supuesto la
victoria del actual campeón argentina
saque el informativo continúen con
nosotros muy buena noche
[Música]